[tires screech]
- HEY, SIR EDNA,
I GOT YOUR BLOOD.
- OKAY.
WHO'S BLOOD IS IT?
NO, DON'T TELL ME.
I UNDERSTAND
SOMETIMES PEOPLE JUST NEED
TO SLIP THROUGH THE CRACKS,
JUST DISAPPEAR.
- WHAT?
NO, IT'S GONNA BE MY BLOOD.
COME ON.
- WHAT?
- TAKE THIS BLADE.
- NO.
NO, NO, NO, WAIT.
- I'M GONNA TAKE THE TUBE,
I'M GONNA PUT IT
RIGHT NEXT TO MY WRIST,
AND YOU'RE GONNA CUT ME.
- NO, KARL,
I--I'M HEMOPHOBIC.
- OH, MY GOD, DERS,
IT'S 2015.
GAY DUDES EXIST.
GET OVER IT.
CUT ME!
- OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
DOLPH LUNDGREN.
- HIT ME, BABY.
- DOLPH LUNDGREN!
- UH, TRY IT AGAIN.
- DOLPH LUNDGREN.
- OKAY, JUST--
YOU KNOW WHAT?
OKAY, GO DOWN THE--
- DOLPH LUNDGREN.
DOLPH LUNDGREN.
- GO DOWN ONE MORE TIME.
- I DON'T KNOW.
- LET ME SEE THE BLADE.
- YEAH.
- [shouts]
- [screams]
- [bleep]!
DOLPH LUNDGREN!
- OKAY.
- DOLPH LUNDGREN!
- OH, OH!
- WHAT ARE YOU--
- WE GOT IT.
- WHY'D YOU LICK IT, MAN?
- I THOUGHT IT WAS LIKE
A BALLPOINT PEN, MAN,
BUT IT'S WORKING.
IT'S WORKING.
- OKAY.
[quivers]